[Música]
en 1966 se dio a conocer al mundo una
condición humana donde los únicos dos
órganos que no estaban paralizados era
el corazón y el cerebro mientras el
corazón bombea la sangre lleva vida a
cada rincón del cuerpo la imaginación la
memoria los pensamientos hacen ruido en
aquella persona que está completamente
paralizada el síndrome del encierro ha
sido diagnosticado aquella persona que
puede ser capaz de ver todo lo que pasa
a su alrededor pero por sí sola no puede
respirar hablar ni moverse solamente con
pequeños movimientos de arriba hacia
abajo pueden expresar en ese estado de
inmovilidad y de frustración por no
cumplir sus anhelos sus pensamientos y
pensamientos más profundos
padecer el síndrome del encierro puede
ser para muchos el fin de una vida para
otros la oportunidad de sacar lo mejor
de sí para poder conectar su mente con
su corazón y es que puede padecer
simplemente un síndrome o una enfermedad
pero para muchos de nosotros es la
imposibilidad de cumplir nuestros más
anhelos nuestros más grandes anhelos si
hoy te invito a mirar a la persona que
tienes al lado qué dirían tus ojos de
los sueños que quieres cumplir
cuáles son esos pensamientos que hacen
ruido en tu cabeza
porque la de tu corazón frente a esos
sueños
solamente la persona que tiene ese
síndrome para salir de ese estado
solamente tiene la posibilidad de
escuchar los latidos de su corazón y es
que olvidamos que mientras haya vida es
la única y verdadera razón la más
importante de que todo es posible
ahora que les cuento sobre ese síndrome
me hacen recordar de lo que de una mujer
que conocí hace bastantes años atrás
tenía apenas 22 años una carrera que
apenas iniciaba en contaduría pública
sus manos inflamadas las 24 horas del
día
imposibilitaban hacer tareas tan simples
como escribir en un computador peinarse
y hasta bañarse a veces ni siquiera
podía caminar los médicos habían
diagnosticado una enfermedad crónica y
de por vida si no te tomas esos
medicamentos vas a terminar en una cama
postrada torcida voces y voces y voces
todas esas voces nos llevan simplemente
a detenernos simplemente a no tomar
acción pero qué era lo que le pasaba a
aquella mujer
qué es la tenía en ese estado
ella debía escuchar su corazón
no olvidemos que el corazón es el primer
órgano que se fecunda cuando llegamos
aquí a la tierra en la naturaleza no
existe ningún error
por algo es el que toma aire
bombea sangre y lleva oxígeno a cada
rincón del cuerpo a cada célula se
imagina son billones de células en
nuestro cuerpo pero escuchamos nuestra
cabeza
aquella mujer ya sus 13 años
tuvo un intento de suicidio porque
estaba cansada de que abusaron de ella
cuando niña imposibilitado de hacerse
visible ante el mundo su amor propio
quedaba en entredicho
era una mujer que no se haga el valor ni
se respetaba vivían experiencias que
simplemente la hacían volver a ese
estado de neutralidad
pero que estaba dispuesta a ella a
realmente salir de ese estado encerrada
en su habitación llorando y pidiéndole a
dios que quería salir realmente de esa
situación tenía que dejar de escuchar
cada uno de sus pensamientos
recordemos que el cerebro se fecunda 18
días después de que empezamos a tener
vida en la barriga de nuestra madre o
sea mucho después de nuestro corazón
pero es el primero al que le ponemos
atención el cerebro tiene neuronas y a
diferencia del corazón que todo ya está
hecho están los vasos sanguíneos las
venas las arterias el corazón forma
surcos neuronales que cada vez que
tenemos una experiencia responde a ella
de la misma manera o sea que se va
llenando durante toda la vida de juicios
creencias emociones
a las cuales les hacemos caso
con cicatrices internas y externas y una
que le recuerda un tumor en su ovario
derecho salvo un sinfín de emociones que
llevaba adentro volvió a su esencia
volvió a reconocerse y no es que cuando
escuchamos nuestro corazón es que nos
volvamos diferentes lo que pasa es que
nos reconocemos y volvemos a ver a
nuestro interior y es ahí donde
potencializa vamos todas nuestras
cualidades no somos diferentes volvemos
a nosotros mismos volvemos a la esencia
verdadera
esta es mi historia
fue un camino difícil de recorrer un
camino en la que hoy puedo sentirme
completamente orgullosa de ella la única
forma de cumplir lo que queramos es
dejando el pasado mirándolos con un amor
aprender de ello y avanzar
así como dice marc anthony en su canción
vivir la vida a veces llega la lluvia
para limpiar las heridas
mirar hacia adelante no mires hacia
atrás como dice diego torres en su
canción color esperanza
pues se puede abrir las ventanas
cambiar el aire depende de ti
o como dice la ley
axel en su canción
celebra la vida celebra la vida
segundo a segundo
todos los días
y tú cuando vas a salir de tu encierro
[Aplausos]